Hello, I am David Kaplan and I am not an expert.
But I hope in this series to learn as much
as possible and explain it to you the best
way I can.
I want to talk about something very serious. I want to talk about the universe
as a fruitcake.
You see, a great description of the expansion of the universe
is that of
an infinite fruitcake which is expanding in all directions
at some constant rate, where
the little pieces of fruit are galaxies and
places where you and I live. That description
is great because it matches the geometry of
the universe. An infinite fruitcake has no
center and so everywhere you are you see things
expanding away from you and the things that
are farther away are expanding faster. So
that is exactly what is happening. We know
the universe is expanding. "Know" in the sense
of we have much more evidence than for most
things that you "know" in your daily life.
So we are very convinced of that. What we
don't really understand is why the fruitcake
is so uniform — why there's pieces of fruit
roughly at constant intervals, and why the
density of the fruitcake may make it taste
quite bad, but at the same time it's uniform
throughout the cake. There's an idea that
at the beginning, or very early times of the
universe, the universe expanded incredibly
quickly in all directions and everything got
flat and everything got uniform and we call
that cosmic inflation. And we wonder if that's
actually true. It's our best guess, but we
don't know. And it was one of those models
where, when it was written down, nobody really
believed we'd have any way of testing it.
But it was a great mathematical construction
to explain the universe. Now, we actually
think we can test some very explicit consequences
of the model and they are basically the ripples
in the fruitcake. There are ripples that are
imprinted on the cake part of the fruitcake
and we are trying to measure those and we
now have the sensitivity. Even though the
fruitcake is very finely grained and the ripples
are very, very subtle, we think we can see
them. So this is about to happen, and if you
see that, then you know where the fruitcake
came from.